o tom é o meu nome é luma ea minha
formação em fotografia e a maioria das
pessoas me perguntam mas fotografia som
fotografia e eu respondi sim só a
fotografia à vontade de dizer 'não' tudo
isso mas a fotografia ela surgiu pela
curiosidade e se firmou pela força da
documentação que ela tem hoje eu enxergo
mais como uma forma de expressão e à
liberdade de poder dizer sem falar me dá
a possibilidade de deixar a conversa
fotógrafo versus espectador um pouco
mais líquido inclusiva
o projeto que eu vim aqui falar hoje ele
precisa ser contextualizado porque por
mais que ele impacto na vida de outras
pessoas
ele começou dentro da minha casa e para
isso é preciso apresentar a vocês meu
pai meu pai se chama jonas ele é
caminhoneiro filho de um caminhoneiro e
diz que ele não escolheu a profissão a
profissão que escolheu e por causa disso
eu cresci na boléia do caminhão que ele
dirigia
eu cresci ouvindo as histórias da
estrada que ele contava ganhando tios
pelo caminho conhecer novas culturas
comendo comida diferente mas chegou uma
hora que a minha vontade é fazer uma
carreira profissional e para isso eu
precisava estudar e me afastar
além disso eu precisava escolher uma
carreira que força de acordo com que as
pessoas esperavam tradicional e que dê
dinheiro ea criatividade a fotografia
não fazer parte disso
pelo não pelos motivos certos escolheu
engenharia o ano de 2012 eu tinha 17
anos
mudei de cidade mudei de amigos era uma
nova rotina
eu tentei tentei tentei tentei muito
mas aquilo não era pra mim eu sabia eu
tava lá vivendo com os meus amigos eles
tinha uma paixão que eu não tinha
eu não enxergava naquela profissão eu
não enxergava meu futuro minha carreira
daquela coisa e eu saí hoje dizer eu
sair é muito fácil
naquela época não ficou foi muito
difícil
só que assim entendeu que eu queria
entender que o que eu queria realmente
fotografar chegar pra minha mãe e dizer
mãe é isso que eu quero
e ela respondeu pra mim graças a deus
menina até que enfim se enxergou isso
foi a principal coisa ea minha maior
motivação para conseguir seguir em
frente
então tomei esse desafio pra mim e fui
estudar fotografia estudar o que eu
queria entender o significado que ela
tinha no mundo e para mim o trabalho que
eu trago aqui hoje é o resultado do meu
trabalho de conclusão de curso
só que pensando nele eu percebi que eu
tenho tomado referências e venho
trabalhando nele desde que eu era
criança nas linhagens mais simples com
meu pai eu nunca vou esquecer de uma
viagem que nós fizemos eu tinha uns 12
anos
nós morávamos na época em coqueiral uma
fazenda dos meus avós no sul de minas
o meu vizinho mais próximo ficava uns 30
minutos de caminhada
então não tinha muitos amigos com o
tempo minha mãe meu pai foram percebendo
isso e viram que eu tava meio tristinha
as filha vamos viajar com seu pai faz
uma viagem com ele falei agora estou
super animada vamos lá viajar com meu
pai eu arrumei uma mala para uma semana
toda empolgada
meu pai todo contente de me contar o
destino vida nas ruas para três corações
gente à cidade de amor e meia de
distância da rede digital mesmo minha
cara de frustração foi evidente
meu pai tentou me consolar flu mas filha
a cidade do pelé que que isso pela minha
vida né gente
mas eu sei que aquela não foi a viagem
mais longa aquela não foi a viagem mais
bonita que nós fizemos
mas eu sei e eu pude entender naquela
viagem que bastava vamos ele a estrada e
eu e tudo estava bem em 2016 nós fizemos
a nossa viagem que é que eu vim fazer
aqui pra vocês nessa nós passamos sete
dias juntos nós somos do sul de minas ao
sul da bahia e voltamos nesses sete dias
eu pedi pra que ele não mudar essa
rotina dele e eu fiquei completamente
desconectado do resto do mundo que
presente ali com ele e esse não mudar a
rotina dele fez com que eu dormisse três
horas por dia tomasse banho e banheiros
de higiene bem duvidosa tomar café da
manhã à meia noite então seguir viagem
novamente essa viagem me fez conhecer
personalidades incríveis me mostrou
pessoas que eu tomava café da manhã que
eu nunca tinha visto na vida e logo
depois eram amigos me fez me apresentou
que tantas que estão há gerações à beira
da estrada se sustentando
mas principalmente ela me mostrou que o
caminhoneiro que está na estrada hoje em
dia ele está por amor só por amor a
história que eu apresento hoje traz o
meu pai como personagem principal de que
enfrentou desafios que viu belas
paisagens e que fez muitos amigos ao
redor
ao final dessa viagem
eu cheguei em casa queria dormir três
dias seguidos
meu pai chegou comeu descansou e seguiu
viagem novamente as fotos que eu trago
aqui elas tenham aponta de crítica
mas mais do que isso elas exaltam esse
profissional que é tão presente em nosso
dia a dia mas que ao mesmo tempo está
ofuscado está apagado e não é lembrado
mas adianta falar falar falar e não
trazer as fotos aqui pra vocês né
agora eu quero mostrar um pouquinho de
como foi a minha viagem com meu país
[Música]
ando devagar porque já tive pressa e
levo esse sorriso porque já chorei de
novo
hoje me sinto mais forte e mais feliz
quem sabe só leva à certeza de que muito
poucos
[Música]
nada sei
conhecer as manhas e as manhãs sabor das
massas e das maçã
[Música]
é preciso amor pra poder pulsar é
preciso paz pra poder sorrir é preciso a
chuva
[Música]
penso que cumprir a vida seja
simplesmente compreender a marcha me
tocando em frente
como velho boiadeiro levando a boiada eu
vou tocando os dias pela ong estrado
extra meu show
[Música]
conhecer as mães
e as manhãs o sabor das massas das maçã
[Música]
é preciso amor pra poder lançar é
preciso paz pra poder sorrir é preciso a
chuva pára foi
todo mundo ama um dia todo mundo chorou
um dia a gente chega no outro vai embora
[Música]
cada um de nós compõem a sua história e
cada ser e se carrega o dom de ser capaz
esse não é porque nós somos o que somos
e estamos onde estamos hoje que nós não
podemos ser diferente amanhã eu fui
estudante de engenharia de som
fotografia não é porque meu pai encontra
a profissão da vida dele os 18 anos que
eu preciso da minha vida planejada
as pessoas que nós mais amamos muito
todos os dias porque a gente não pode
fazer isso com nós mesmos
foi muito difícil para mim aceitar que
era importante a minha presença aqui
hoje mas meu pai me fez acreditar em mim
o ensinou que toda a história vale ser
ouvida
pode ser que não seja o que você queria
ouvir hoje mas pode ser que o colega do
lado
pode ser para amanhã
eu não sou
não gosto de pensar não quero pensar que
eu estou no meu limite de possibilidades
nem como fotógrafa nem com o filho de
jonas da cleary estou muito feliz aqui e
tinha obrigado por tudo
[Música]